un mystérieux sarcophage de plomb a été
retrouvé sous notre dame on t'explique
et entre résume ce qu'on sait sur la
personne qui se trouve à l'intérieur en
fait depuis les incendies du 15 avril
2019 la cathédrale fait l'objet de
travaux notamment pour reconstruire la
flèche qui s'est effondré pour installer
un échafaudage 200 m des fouilles ont dû
être menée au préalable pour garantir la
solidité du sol et c'est lors de ces
fouilles que cette découverte
surprenante a donc été fait un
sarcophage de forme humaine en plomb
grâce à une mini caméra les archéologues
ont pu confirmer qu'on voyait encore du
tissu des cheveux et des feuilles au
dessus de la tête ce qui indique un état
de conservation très bon des fouilles
plus précises vont devoir être faites en
laboratoire pour en savoir un peu plus
sur la personne inhumé mais on a déjà
quelques informations selon ministère de
la culture au regard des
caractéristiques et de la localisation
du sarcophage l'hypothèse d'une
sépulture d'un haut dignitaire de
l'église semble probable et d'après la
première analyse des éléments à
proximité du sarcophage l'inhumation
d'attrait au plus tard du 14e siècle
c'est pas la première fois qu'on
retrouve une sépulture à notre dame mais
selon les experts c'est la première fois
qu'on retrouve un sarcophage aussi bien
conservé